it has finally begun sam mellinger the
kansas city star reports that the chiefs
and quarterback patrick mahomes have
commenced negotiations on a second
contract the window opened at the
conclusion of the 2019 regular season
had from homes has not been clamoring
for a contract hasn't been jostling
hasn't been demanding that something get
done he said all the right things now
it's time for the two sides to do the
right thing and big cat this is
something you and i have spoken about
earlier
the idea that what mahomes needs
is a percentage of the salary cap the
cap is going to keep going up it may dip
a little bit next year you have a set
salary in there to protect against a
reduction but you want to share in the
ongoing growth of the cap so you never
get leap frogged by anyone else as the
market goes up your pay goes up the
salary cap goes up and you always are
leaving a set percentage of the pie
behind if you get 17 percent there's
always 83 cents on the dollar for the
rest of the team to be put around you
that is the best way to protect patrick
mahomes against what becomes a bad
contract in a few years that's what they
need to do it's permissible
players have tried to get that term the
teams have resisted i think the league
doesn't want teams to do it this is the
guy if anyone's going to get it it's
going to be patrick mahomes
yeah i i would love to be a fly on the
wall for this negotiation just imagining
that patrick mahomes and his agent show
up and they're like so
we just want all the money and they just
have a nice hearty laugh and they're
like sure deal no problem we'll give you
all the money that sounds like a good
deal for us because when when was last
time something like this has happened
mike where it's a guy who has won a
quarterback or won a super bowl so
quickly
uh and has such insane skill level
that it's like not even a question it's
not even a question i mean i'm thinking
back peyton manning obviously was a no
doubter but he hadn't won a super bowl
ben roethlisberger won a super bowl but
he wasn't great in that super bowl he
wasn't patrick mahomes i mean he was
probably the worst winning super bowl
quarterback at the time um
i'm trying like who who else has ever
been in this specific point where
they're year three four of their career
artists
title
russell wilson there it is so yeah so
there it is
and russell wilson stays among the
highest paid quarterbacks in the nfl and
he was never an mvp of uh either a super
bowl or the nfl regular season mahomes
nfl mvp 2018 super bowl mvp 2019 and
look here's the thing he has said he
doesn't want to to put the chiefs in a
spot where they can't put talent around
him peyton manning's position always was
it's my job to get paid as much as money
as i can it's your job to manage the
salary cap i don't think mahomes is
going to take that approach he could and
you could argue that he should i think
the best protection is say whatever the
salary cap is i get 18 cents of every
dollar or 19. whatever they negotiate
that and let the dollars figure
themselves out based upon what the cap
is do you think peyton manning ever
regrets that do you ever think he looks
back and he's like hey we had a couple
teams that were pretty close but a piece
away they still had a good team around
him they still had no idea around him
yeah but there were definitely years
where they were you know the their
defense wasn't up to par and having an
extra player or two would have would
have made the difference
look at what tom brady did though how
many how much can we really point to
what the patriots did to take advantage
of the money that tom brady didn't
insist on now they had a here's the key
they had a strong middle class of
backups that's the key and and that's
that here's where i'll concede your
point
peyton manning had plenty of guys around
when those guys got hurt they had to go
with young guys who maybe couldn't step
up the patriots always had those
veterans in backup roles who could come
in and not miss a beat that was how they
benefited from tom brady taking
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports